I've been playing around with my own revision
to the haidt's scales, because I've thrown
out haidt's model, which I think is wrong.
And I've rejiggered his items to make a better
version of his scale,
where instead of measuring these stupid five
moral foundations,
I found that really there's just two.
And that the best way of getting at how they
actually collapse into the political left-right
continuum is to have a tilt.
So you have individualizing, and binding moral
foundations,
and then you just compute the difference score
between them.
And that gives you a left and a right.
It's quite nice, actually, because people
high on binding tend to be high on group-oriented
behaviors.
They tend to be high on religion, they tend
to be high on community orientation.
Whereas people who are high on individualizing
also tend to be overly concerned with equality,
and their own status relative to others.
So really there's just this one dimension
there.
And I've been finding that it correlates quite
strongly with measures of home brokenness,
whether there's been experiences of violence
in the childhood environment.
We've got correlations between individualizing
tilt, and having come from a home where the
subject was exposed to violence as a child.
So it looks like violence in the home may
begat leftist moral foundations through possibly
some epigenetic route.
Well, you're saying that people who are leftist
are more likely to have experienced violence
in the home.
Yes, that's right.
It could also be that there are genetic correlations
there between genes that predispose one towards
dysfunctionality and violence,
and also genes that predispose one towards
being incredibly self rather than other focused,
as that seems to be characteristic of those
who score high on these individualizing moral
foundations.
And we found a lot of the concern for equality
is not born out of an existential concern
for people.
It's born out of a, where do I rank relative
to others, and how can I pull others down
towards me, and how can I level the playing
field in my favor?
Gerhard Meisenberg has done a very interesting
book review of Superior by Angela Saini,
in which he argues this is true of her, that
she is only interested in those who are in
her group.
And you're only in her group if you're equal
to her.
And if you're not equal to her, then you're
not in her group.
So it's the ultimate selfishness.
Yeah, the big idea I've been trying to tie
my head around, which is based on the idea
that it doesn't make sense initially
to think of people who are highly individualistic,
as being also high on equality preferences.
But when you think about it in this way, it
makes a lot of sense.
Moreover, it leads one to the conclusion that
there exists a form of positive and negative
egalitarianism.
Just as there are positive and negative forms
of ethnocentrism and misogyny, there are also
positive and negative forms of egalitarianism.
And the egalitarianism which is based on leveling
and elimination of differences in order to
raise comparative advantage,
would be a negative specie of egalitarianism.
Whereas the egalitarianism where you're concerned
about the overall condition of the poor,
and you believe that there's some role for
charity in ameliorating the hardships, of
what the Victorian era referred to as the
deserving poor.
Or conversely, you are someone who is very
concerned with the possibility of people becoming
so wealthy,
that in so doing, they start to damage the
interests of their corporate polity.
That form of egalitarianism, which is not
a leftist egalitarianism,
it's more of a kind of rightist egalitarianism,
because it often gels with traditional notions
of how societies should be structured,
and put together and limited.
If you look at distributism as a model of
economics, for example, and the social teachings
of the Catholic Church in the 20s and 30s
and things,
you can see lots of evidence of this positive
egalitarianism, where it's born out of a real
concern for how excessive inequality
can damage the corporate well-being.
Sorry, these negative egalitarians, they want
to suppress the evidence of the existence
of differences between groups of people.
Well, they don't want to suppress evidence
of the existence of differences, they're happy
to accept that there are differences.
It's the etiology of the differences.
They don't want any talk about the differences
being caused by genetics.
They're very happy to talk about the differences
being caused by oppression.
So they get very uncomfortable if you point
out that socioeconomic status and IQ are genetically
correlated,
and actually share variance through a common
set of apparently causal variance.
They don't like you using polygenic scores
for IQ to predict differences in educational
attainment and socioeconomic status.
Why do you think that's the case?
It's a very interesting question.
I have to think about it some more.
This is something I want to get at through
scale construction.
I actually want to try and build a scale and
instrument that I can validate,
that can measure and differentiate between
these two types of egalitarianism,
just as there are scales for positive and
negative ethnocentrism, which have already
been validated,
I would like to build a similar one for egalitarianism.
But as to why that might be the case, maybe
these people who are high on negative egalitarianism
(as Darwin says) bear the indelible stamp
of their lowly origins.
And they don't want to think any aspect of
their past, or any aspect of their immediate
familial history is an impediment to their
perceived actual social success.
It struck me as consistent with what you were
saying about left-wing people having had more
violent childhoods.
And they, on some sort of cognitive dissonance
level, realize that nature is red in tooth
and claw,
and they are a product of that.
That's what's made them who they are,
these big genetic indelible differences.
And they just can't deal with knowing that.
Well, actually a colleague of mine who's been
teaching for a very, very long period of time,
he has noted anecdotally that those who are
the most resistant to behavior genetic perspectives,
are typically those who self-identify as having
come from a background of dysfunctionality.
And they don't want to think that their background,
in terms of their familial background and
the generally dysfunctional context from which
they arose,
could play any kind of a role in making them
who they are.
They want to believe in a super free will.
They want your person and your process of
self-actualization
to be completely decoupled from genetic constraints.
And they want this process of personal evolution,
essentially, to be
entirely independent of anything that could
hold them back.
Our character is entirely in our own hands.
Don't forget that, my baby.